[Musica]
buonasera qualche giorno fa è stato il
primo d'aprile e come ha sottolineato un
fortunato meme diffuso sui social
network è l'unico giorno dell'anno in
cui ci premuriamo di verificare la
veridicità delle informazioni che
leggiamo su internet una cosa che forse
dovremmo fare anche negli altri 364
giorni dell'anno
quindici anni fa mentre stavo preparando
il concorso per il dottorato di ricerca
mi sono imbattuto in una vicenda molto
intrigante la storia di un bandito del
xvi secolo che come accade spesso era
nato vissuto e morto in maniera un po
rocambolesca e questa sua vita
rocambolesca aveva ispirato diverse
versioni della vicenda
e mentre leggevo le fonti mi accorgevo
che ogni fonte dava una versione diversa
sembrava che questo personaggio storico
reale proiettasse una sorta di prisma di
diversi personaggi a seconda delle volte
in cui era stata letta è raccontata la
sua vicenda
naturalmente è un tema estremamente
ampio che è stato studiato da studiosi
membri autorevoli di me per l'ente ma
che mi ha lanciato un po sulla strada di
questa idea cioè cercare di studiare il
modo in cui gli eventi storici che si
sono svolti realmente vengono percepiti
ricordati e tramandati c'è un'immagine
di leonardo da vinci che mi piace
diciamo associare un po questo
procedimento
questo è uno schizzo per una battaglia
l'artista voluto raffigurare un
cavaliere nell'atto di attaccare ea
seconda delle diciamo dei punti di vista
e dei momenti in cui lo raffigurava
quest'uomo era più arrabbiato grintoso
oa volte semplicemente molto serio e
compreso nel suo ruolo
ecco un po così appare anche nelle fonti
storiche il personaggio che ho indagato
ma non vi parlerò di lui oggi vorrei
parlarvi di due casi di veri falsi
storici ovvero due casi reali in cui la
storia è stata ingannata
e modificata il primo è molto antico
2500 anni fa pausania grande e generale
spartano dopo aver sconfitto la platea i
persiani entra in scontro con i vertici
della coalizione greca e così viene
costretto a ritirarsi dal suo ruolo di
stratega e continua la sua guerra in
maniera sostanzialmente privata ma dopo
un po di assenza dalla sua patria sparta
deve rientrare e lì si trova invischiato
in una trappola
infatti qualcuno ha consegnato agli e
fori che governano sparta delle lettere
in cui lui offre al grande nemico cioè
rsr dei persiani che lui ha sconfitto in
battaglia
un'occasione unica cioè di varcare le
porte della grecia conquistare tutta la
civiltà ellenica in cambio di che cosa
della mano di sua figlia
quindi diciamo che pausania il grande
eroe spartano stava vendendo la sua
patria al nemico in cambio della gloria
personale pausa ne viene condannato a
morte per queste lettere e si rifugia
nel tempio di athena perché vuole
rifugiarsi godendo del diritto di asilo
in questo tempio le autorità lo
inseguono e non potendo catturarlo in un
luogo sacro decidono di murare le porte
del tempio e così pausania muore di fame
e di sete all'interno del tempio
ora già all'epoca di tucidide che ci
racconta questa storia
alcuni avevano il forte dubbio che
quelle lettere fossero false fossero dei
falsi prodotti dai nemici di pausania
per incastrarlo
ora dopo secoli di filologia e di
indagine storica
noi siamo sostanzialmente certi che
quelle lettere fossero false sono che
andate a dirla pausania che per colpa di
un falso è stato ucciso davvero è un po
qualcosa di simile a quello che è
successo nel 1924 inghilterra quando a
quattro giorni dalle elezioni una
lettera di grigorij zinovyev viene
pubblicata in cui lui sostanzialmente
pianificava assieme al partito comunista
inglese
l'idea d'inglobare l'inghilterra nel
blocco sovietico
questo ovviamente causa
un crollo nei consensi del partito
comunista inglese
la lettera era un falso ma ormai la
storia va preso il suo la sua direzione
il secondo esempio invece è molto più
leggero almeno per noi che lo osserviamo
per il protagonista non è stato molto
leggero 1725 in germania
johan the ringer è uno studioso di
storia naturale che è convinto diciamo
di una teoria che a noi sono un po
bizzarra cioè lui è convinto che i
fossili non siano oggetti naturali ma
siano delle sculture realizzate da una
forza soprannaturale forse dalla volontà
di dio stesso per raffigurare il creato
sulla pietra allora di questa sua
convinzione si approfittano due suoi
colleghi molto burloni i quali decidono
di realizzare dei finti fossili che
raffigurano animali piante insetti e
anche se come volevano strafare delle
scritte in ebraico e cosa fanno gli
seppelliscono nel campo dove beringer va
a fare le sue indagini archeologiche
quando lui trova questi fossili non gli
sembra vero e si innamora di questa di
questa scoperta meravigliosa e decide di
scrivere un volume su questa vicenda
nonostante alcuni gli consigliassero una
maggiore prudenza perché era un po
sospetta sospetto questo ritrovamento ma
lui era talmente convinto che decise di
pubblicare questo volume è solo dopo la
pubblicazione del volume i due
rivelarono la burla
alcuni sostengono che behringer abbia
passato il resto della sua vita a dare
la caccia alle copie del suo volume per
distruggerle cancellare la traccia di
questa vergogna un po simile a quello
che è successo nel 1984 a livorno con le
famose teste di modigliani che portarono
scompiglio nel mondo della critica
d'arte e rovinando anche qualche
reputazione in realtà si trattava di
falsi scolpiti e gettati in questo
canale apposta per essere ritrovati
questo per dirvi come ci siano delle
lunghe continuità in questi temi bene
perché vi ho raccontato queste
diciamo questi due casi perché il primo
ci racconta il perché cioè la maggior
parte dei falsi storici ai tempi di
pausania come oggi vengono prodotti per
indirizzare l'opinione pubblica per
convincere il pubblico o le autorità a
far prendere alla storia una determinata
direzione che altrimenti non verrebbe
presa un perlomeno non così rapidamente
il secondo esempio perché ci spiega un
pochino come ovvero ci rivela che in
molti casi noi che veniamo ingannati dai
falsi storici
vogliamo essere ingannati perché
troviamo in questi falsi qualche cosa in
cui sono stati foto sotto insomma
credevamo già e quindi troviamo una
conferma ora vi vorrei dare tre piccole
indicazioni diciamo le vorrei dare hanno
anche a me stesso tre indicazioni
generali molto semplici la prima è
teniamo sempre acceso il cervello
soprattutto quando siamo in rete non
dobbiamo mai pensare che sia alla rete a
pensare per noi dobbiamo essere sempre
noi a controllare e quindi se per
esempio incontriamo una notizia che ci
fa spalancare la bocca per la meraviglia
per l'orrore o per la soddisfazione
poniamoci il problema se così
incredibile può darsi che semplicemente
non sia vera quindi valutiamo con
lucidità la seconda è verifica la fonte
lo so che è noioso verificare le fonti
però quando incontriamo una notizia che
ci sembra sospetta
controlliamo intanto se la fonte che
cela riferisce e autorevole
secondo se la fonte a sua volta cita
delle fonti o se quella notizia è nata
dal nulla e terza cosa se qualcun altro
parla di questo evento straordinario
se queste tre condizioni non si
verificano aspettiamo
concediamoci un supplemento di
riflessione
il terzo consiglio in realtà il più
importante di tutti perché è un po il
prerequisito per gli altri due ed è
contrastiamo il pregiudizio di conferma
il pregiudizio di conferma e quell
errore cognitivo che sostanzialmente
ci spinge e opera su tutti e non è che
questo non è che soltanto gli stupidi
soltanto gli incolti tutti noi siamo
vittime del pregiudizio di conferma e
quell'errore cognitivo che ci spinge a
selezionare i dati della realtà
scegliendo e valorizzando quelli che
vanno incontro alle nostre convinzioni
pregresse e scartando o per lo meno
considerando con minore
considerazione quelli che vanno contro
le nostre convinzioni per cui una
notizia che conferma ciò che noi già
pensavamo la valorizziamo e magari la
condividiamo sui social network o la
riferiamo ad altri una che va contro
tendiamo un po accantonarla ovviamente è
quello che è successo a joan the ringer
cioè lui era talmente convinto talmente
innamorato della sua tesi da non
valutare come attendibili tutte e tutti
gli avvertimenti che riceveva da
corrotti gli dicevano calma e della
stessa cosa che è successa anche
recentemente vi faccio un esempio di
pochi anni fa quando è stato eletto papa
ratzinger
molti hanno guardati insomma questo
questo teologo così duro così tedesco
con un po di sospetto e nei primi giorni
è saltata fuori questa immagine è un
sacco di gente ha detto l'ho beccato è
finalmente ti ho beccato a rivelare la
tua vera natura
quelli che avevano un po più di dubbi
sono andati avanti nella ricerca hanno
scoperto questa immagine quindi con un
semplice taglio dell'immagine si passa
da papà che benedice a papà che fa il
saluto nazista papa che benedice papa
che fa saluto nazista
ecco questo per dire che anche in anni
recenti con le tecnologie quella
consapevolezza eccetera eccetera
a volte certe idee che abbiamo dentro e
di cui siamo convinti ci spingono un po
in errore
attenzione il pregiudizio di conferma
non è che sia totalmente un elemento
negativo infatti gli studiosi ci dicono
che anche delle varie positive per
esempio una parte del suo della sua
valenza positiva per rassicurarci sulla
permanenza della nostra diciamo delle
nostre convinzioni e anche della nostra
coerenza con il nostro gruppo
d'appartenenza
cioè ci dice che sì noi la pensiamo così
e apparteniamo comunque a una comunità
che ritiene che quell'opinione sia
valida
diciamo che è un po il diapason che ci
assicura che stiamo ancora belando nella
stessa tonalità del nostro gregge
non c'è niente di male di per sé nel
fatto di avere un greggio almeno di
avere un gruppo di appartenenza perché a
tutti noi piace comunque fare il viaggio
in buona compagnia con qualcuno con cui
condividiamo una visione del mondo e
farlo anche su strade sicure già battute
da altre però è questa e diciamola come
dicono gli esperti di comunicazione alla
call to action che vorrei lanciarvi oggi
proviamo a fare diciamo le cose in
maniera contraria al nostro come siamo
abituati cioè quando troviamo una
informazione che soddisfa pienamente le
nostre convinzioni
proviamo a metterla in dubbio a metterla
sotto stress ea cercare di verificarla e
d'altra parte quando troviamo una
notizia che ci fa arrabbiare che
smentisce quelli in cui credevamo
proviamo a darle un attimo fiducia ea
provare a verificarla per vedere che
magari semplicemente non avessimo torto
noi sicuramente ci troveremo un pochino
spaesati
ma è anche vero che è solo cambiando
strada che si scoprono delle nuove nuovi
territori per noi e per gli altri è a
posto di sona retorico vi dico che se
cristoforo colombo avesse creduto alle
convinzioni della sua comunità di
riferimento
forse insomma la storia sarebbe andata
diversamente
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]